okay so this is a real quick spoiler
corner because like there's not that
much to spoil Hawkeye is living the life
of the Waltons
yeah pretty much I guess like a family
he's made building up like you know I
don't have a girlfriend he has like a
family with a wife who's pregnant with
another wheel turns out he just going to
it apparently they're like retconning
characters now stuff Oh what was he game
a comic no no no but I'm saying maybe
they just pulled that with Iceman yeah
you never know
yes that was fun I thought this
interesting cuz when it's all said and
done he's actually more boring than
Captain America when it comes to is kind
of like just personal life and like it's
like no I it's so endearingly like
normal with the white picket fence and
the father no but you know they're there
it's endearingly bored yeah and I think
that's what makes it work because he's
got a bow and arrow and he's you know
like badass and like working in business
in met like he just comes home to this
picket fence like I gotta think Captain
America's jealous because I won for that
fucking glacier there I would be well
and they sort of address all that too
it's like you know there's a nice moment
where they go and like you know they're
not not giving along but they've all
taken lot as they put it like we took a
hit when I like the character
development at the end with Captain
America saying well I thought I had this
then I was trapped here we all know
Peggy had Alzheimer's and you know and
so now he's just like I'm home like for
him Hawkeye will have his family what
Captain America always wanted but now
Captain America's just reconcile them
something's like I've got this team like
the team is now my home I'm the leader
like I guess this is it for me and then
between then the other line about oh I
got a dark side too pal like I think
they're setting things up for Civil War
so yeah I I like that Quicksilver is
dead
yeah which to be fair I mean it's he was
in a bad character or anything but it's
not like I wasn't like oh no
I bet they're making it look like
Hawkeye is gonna die me right down to
the given the family and I'll be home
and stuff like that sigh I didn't want
to see him go
so I okay as much as it's a Whedon
project and he'll just kill anybody off
I looked at that I'm like no way no
studio in their right minds gonna let
them write her a split I'm like you know
that even women then like I'm like
Whedon maybe but I'm like Marvel Studios
and Disney or whatever you don't have
the balls so they don't know if they did
that like after that set up with that
family making him so likable and me
people would just be like that means it
would have been great though I would you
know at least for storytelling purpose
though that would have been great that I
probably was robbing a civil war
obviously that would have been like the
point where it up be but it also would
have stopped like half of people from
coming back right now this is always
Marvel's kind of downfall least in these
movies is there isn't a lot of sacrifice
going on it's like they go in they get
their butts kicked but then they come
out just like and everything's fine
oh no we lost a side character hmm like
so you know I I would have been okay
with it from a storytelling perspective
I would have been the same way where you
kill about you bastards you suck but I
still would have secretly been like yeah
that's a good move um when uh and then
the ending I had to me like I I'm not
totally sure I follow cuz they're
building up it's like okay so here's all
you know like whatever I think a Scarlet
Witch is there and the new glowy stone
forehead is their vision the name is
okay vision is there I think it's vision
it's supposed to be all right
for the sake of like comets being really
glowy stone for a guy that I want
friggin the fuck out of the wings what
the hell's his name Archangel okay no no
the other one
Oh x-men no they get all the wing guys
are teens yeah she is something I think
people should just calm wing map um but
he's there so so all of these are about
talk guys
[Music]
so so so about four of these people
wanted us and you see Iron Man and Hulk
walking off or another the Iron Man and
maybe Hawkeye actually okay so it's
Captain America Black Widow and then
like these three or four other what Hulk
is go on he kind of vanished in a yeah
in a play it was just a little weird but
it's like whatever we're setting up to
go find they'll find him in the next
movie and yeah and yeah so they had
these other three or four Avengers and
Captain America comes things like
adventurers and then it cuts to the
credits and I'm thinking to myself okay
if Avengers 3 is these people like I'll
see it but you know you're gonna lose
lawyers whole or where is Hulk where's
Tony's yeah you know you're gonna lose
like half your audience doing that so I
doubt they're going to I think it's more
like they're just
I love late when they cut it when they
cook Captain America offshore to like
the crowd I saw with like all these he's
one boss and they really pay that they
all stayed to the end yeah they were not
happy there's nothing there I was really
pissed as you know but to prank me yeah
no killing Quicksilver right well
because we've got the x-men films I
don't know if he's gonna come back and
that god only knows what deal they had
to cut with freakin Fox what up from
what I heard they're just doing
different universes like the spots on
the prop like is it like a spider-man
deal with Sony like I don't get that
they make some sort what would I hurt
him Studios and their overlap like I
don't know what the deal with Fox's but
I thought maybe that was the issue why
they're just like okay just get them in
this movie and get them out and then
that way we don't have to worry I think
you'd like a like a clever tie it but I
don't think it's like official as far as
I know they're still gonna be like
Magneto's kids I think so yeah yeah so
it's like from what I heard this movie's
not out yet obviously but you know I
heard they were gonna be still in there
and like it different universe but you
know the one thing we didn't touch upon
I like to yeah
I think I liked the Fox version of
Quicksilver the way they did those
effects better overall but I don't know
oh that's right he wasn't Days of Future
past yeah well let's say Quicksilver I
thoughts just an hour fast mutant I
thought was supposed to be quick so I
thought was a fast me to crap now around
the cabin so whatever there I thought am
i insane I thought that was I felt how
if you're making like whether you're um
I could be wrong be there's gotta be a
million fast mutants you know in the
x-men universe but but you know one
thing we didn't touch upon though in a
regular view I just realized would you
think the romance between Hulk and Black
Widow I thought it was very cute the way
she settles him down and you know this
and that
I feel like yeah I like that too I
thought that was pretty I didn't see I
only saw that first damningly Hulk movie
that swore me off Hulk movies ever since
so I don't know where they went with the
character after that there was the
Edward Norton version there's not yeah I
I don't know I don't feel like I know
the Hulk really any much better I know
Black Widow a little better so I thought
it was good but then they kind of end of
it and they split up and I I don't know
see this is my problem with the Avengers
and a lot of T movies is there's so many
characters that you know it's hard to
say like because some people are
commenting that well this movie feels
rushed and it does and yeah that's still
2 hours 45 minutes long because there
are times where like man this movie
feels long so like I don't know if
there's a director's cut coming out of
it sweden from Christ knows it probably
will be but yeah so I I don't know I
like the idea I like what I saw I wish I
could have seen more you know the funny
thing is that for me like in the first
film there's definitely times like you
know in the opening
and then like somewhere in the middle
and stuff like that we might watch a
little bit in this one actually for the
most part I was pretty sucked in I was
pretty engaged until the ending would
you still find is an impressive
spectacle flying first yeah and then I
felt like yeah we're hanging out here
too long yeah it was a awesome at first
and then it kind of kept going and I'm
like oh my god somebody either die or
blow something up yeah we're the first
on the action was so well done because
as soon as Hulk hits that metal whale
and you think like it's winding down be
you don't want it to win I said yeah the
rest it's like oh my god this gave me
exactly what I did you forget like I
think on this tree was nail but that
carrier scene in the first one went on
for freaking ever well you know that's
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
like the climax I said film was
brilliant we're nearly on no no no I'm
saying the carrier scene in the first
film
oh no but I've gone on forever where's
this one the middle action scenes I
think we're way more perfectly paced and
the climax was kind of long ya know in
the first film I thought the last you
know third was just and that was
perfectly paced and done as you can get
for a climax and then this one you know
and and the rest of it is good it's a
good movie and then this one I thought
majority of it was really actually
really good and engaging stuff in the
climax was good it's a good climax but
again I I'm not expecting anything to
like really back me out the part in the
first bill so it is my kind of a switch
around but yeah I'm with you I would
like tale' ittle bit more but I guess
that's kind of that's kind of a setup -
it's like I'm gonna say this I don't
think this is I'm Whedon by the way I
think this is just a Marvel Studios
saying I see another fucking shot of fan
oohs not doing jack shit I'm sweating
pissed now
because every time I'm doing myself o
nuttin was guardians of the galaxy I'm
like well at least he's kind of doing
something but at least saying more than
like my putting on the gauntlet and just
be like hard don't do it myself I'm like
okay it's only been like how many
fucking movies look oh god yeah familis
is pretty fucking lazy have you just
sitting there like you
it's just a couch potatoes sitting in
that throat it is like do what you will
boy but know that I am all-powerful
because I never have to get up out of
this chair to put my gauntlet on then I
go back in the chair
yeah I mean it's like it at first cuz
everyone went nuts fucking saw his first
filming now it's like we're kind of
getting tired you're setting yourself up
the other problem is you're setting
yourself up a little bit for disaster
when you do this because the hype and
wait for this now is gonna be so long
than when they do finally get to that
whole Infinity Gauntlet thing you'd
better pray it's the most perfect thing
you'd better be Avengers times 12 like
yeah like everybody's expectation now
that's a different character actually
okay yeah everybody's expectations are
gonna be so freakin high that like me
because it's just been like it how many
years is it gonna be now like plus 10
years building up to this so god help
you Marvel you better know what you're
doing I mean generally you have an idea
of what you're doing but yeah it's gonna
be perfect damn so just be like you ever
talk to you like when it finally comes
it's like whatever infinity war you know
that Alyssa tax or Thanos destroys the
world or whatever and people go see the
movie it's just like you know Marvel
presents we got your money and it's just
gonna be them like doing coke off of
prostitutes and like you know doing this
was the money itself like what else when
we saw the trailer for ant-man I'm just
like it's so funny when you see marvels
ant-man it's like it should just be
Marvel's anything damn well throw it to
you marbles phone book but it's like it
looks good as it does and I still would
have loved a tie-in with ultra work on
work on that one Whedon I saw like smart
ass I can't think of too much else so
yeah it's still a good movie yeah still
good no it's terrible
ah I'm like the first I don't like how
they could they make it look like the
guy continued to
another film unlike the first it's just
getting horrible reviews just miserable
reviews a whole 75 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes this may be the worst movie of
this year downfall this is like Pixar's
Cars refers to you know maybe maybe
Ultron was right humanity should be
eliminated
let's get out